as you'll know Oscar Wilde is quite
famous for long roads one of them goes
as follows
if you want to tell people the truth
make them love otherwise they might kill
you as you might have guessed we're
going to talk about humor and more
specifically about its function and its
overall significance and effective
communication let me start first with a
story an anecdote once upon a time there
was a king's court and there was a
beloved and very successful jester who
the muse the king and all the people by
the king but one day he actually crossed
the line abated and he insulted his King
the king was completely infuriated so he
ordered that the Jester be executed now
what happened was that the court which
loved the the Jester pleaded by the king
to at least let it just decide on the
way that he should die the King actually
granted that request and asked the
gesture and the Jester threw his form he
said my lord if it's all the same to you
I shall prefer to die of old age so in
that sort of whimsical and humorous
response the jest was able to save his
own life on a more realistic and serious
note from real life that gentleman
behind me is normal cousins he was a
professor of medicine at the UC Berkeley
in 1964 I think the 1960s he did a trip
to Russia he came back and he had
contracted serious heart disease what he
chose for his treatment along a lot of
scientific and medical options was to
include laughter and comedy as part of
his therapeutic methods so he'd watch
funny funny films he'd listen to to the
funny clips he'd actually try to laugh
more and he look he realized that
laughter and humor really had an
aesthetic effect similar to that of
painkillers but now let's move from the
realm of anecdotes and store
to the actual science behind humor and
its use in our lives and in effective
communication
angela is going to give us a deep dive
into the real science so what is humor
and more importantly how can it help us
when we think about communicating a
hundred years ago Charles Darwin
compared humor to tickling of the brain
and actually it turned out that he
wasn't that far off I'm going to give
you the one-minute sort of humorless
overview of what humor does to our
brains and bodies and why it's so
important to include as a communication
tool so studies have found that humor
impacts us in three ways first it's good
for our minds second it's good for our
bodies and third it improves our social
relationships in terms of our brains you
can see behind me the composite results
of hundreds of studies that were done on
different types of patients on different
types of jokes the big level takeaway is
that humor engages your entire brain and
this is why it's so good for engaging
your attention and improving your memory
the other thing that we can notice about
brain and humor is that it's a two-step
process first
cognitive processes kicked in and second
and emotional process kicks in that
allows us to actually enjoy a joke in
other words it's something that
encompasses our whole being when we find
something funny second humor is good for
our bodies medical studies have shown
that when we laugh our muscles relax our
blood pressure drops and actually our
immunity is even boosted so the science
actually shows that humor is good as a
medicine for disease and finally third
as we've all experienced humor is good
for our social relationships it allows
us to defuse tension in a situation or
address a difficult topic in a way that
kind of allows us to laugh together so
with these three and reasons in mind why
humor can be such a powerful
communication tool
Mahmood is going to walk us through some
practical examples of this in practice
and how it can really work um
we looked at three areas where the humor
could be used in a good way to improve
our our presentation skills basically
the first one is introducing levity and
here's the bit about dealing with
complex situation and we want to make
sure we said we sent the message very
simply and in such a nice way to the
audience the second the second area
where we looked at is making the message
very powerful there is a statement that
we use there is a phrase that we use and
the business is cool when we are
describing the product market fit which
basically goes like you want the food to
eat there on dog food and basically that
phrase has been said in 1970 and we
still remember that because of the humor
aspect of it and the third area where
humor could be used very effectively in
presentation and the presentation is to
break the eyes as engage very nicely
with your audience
we then throw out the clause that that
having a conversation with the audience
is a such a nice way to reduce the
anxiety and now let's let's look at one
example where we thought leavitt humor
was used very nicely in levity in the
White House Correspondents basically it
said dinner where be with the president
of the United State and in this case
Barack Obama getting an event with the
national press and DC and basically they
take a moment to relax get out of their
weed and laugh and if you look at their
kind of interaction in the past year
they basically going mm and those two
toes together and and if you look at the
if you look at the basically at the
dinner you would feel um three things
that impact you first off first of all
the first impact that it had in our
service the person comes like a very
natural and authentic and basically
bring the the human aspect of them and
make us connect with them very well this
the second thing that we we felt
impact on ourself when we looked at the
White House correspondent
it's basically help the whole thing to
reset and start a new conversation and
the third one is basically we punish the
energy and engage in more serious
conversation in the future so let's have
a look I usually start these dinners
with a few self-deprecating jokes
after my stellar 2013 what could I
possibly talk about I admit it
last year was rough sheesh and one point
things got so bad the 47% called Mitt
Romney to apologize
of course we rolled out healthcare.gov
that could have gone better the second
thing we want to talk about is using
humor to amplify the power of your
message so in this class we've seen
clips from The Daily Show and one of the
things we noticed is that Jon Stewart is
incredibly effective at bringing humor
to the specific political issues that he
wanted to focus on and he wanted to
highlight we thought that this is an
incredibly incredibly effective way to
make his message even more poignant but
we wanted to bring it something that we
could relate to that's a national scale
on a daily basis we wanted to think
about the GSB every year the GSB puts on
the GSB show it allows the writers of
the show to perhaps make their own
statements about the environment that
they go to school in this clip they've
taken a panel and the panel is basically
serving as the staff that looks over
kind of everything that we have to do to
schedule which has its fair share of red
tape this is how they decided to present
it or see like this there's a message
there that perhaps more bluntly couldn't
be communicated but using humor as its
vehicle I think they get their point
across now we have to say at this point
we're very aware of our pandering we're
going to go from JD's favorite person
Jon Stewart today to Dee's actual
favorite person Kendall
we think humor is an incredibly
effective way at creating comfort with
your audience both for the speaker and
for the audience
everyone in this class went through the
exercise with Ken and all that was meant
to do was bring down our anxiety so that
when we were randomly called to the
stage we were able to effectively
communicate with our audience we wanted
to focus on the humor of that in that
span in that class we laughed we laughed
a lot we were uncomfortable but what we
saw by the end of that was incredibly
effective communication across a couple
different functions we saw great posture
we saw a lot of confidence in the way
that you stood and Deliver we saw much
fewer filler words which to us suggests
a great comfort with who you're
presenting to we saw creative topics I
think we all remember Abby's love for
the green juice blender and we just saw
a compelling presence one of the things
that we love about humor is that we
think it gives you a presence to your
audience
now we'll ask Manolis to come wrap it up
so it is quite clear that here we're
going to be very very powerful agents
and a very partial tool in your verbal
and nonverbal communication what we'd
like you to remember is that humor is
tied to the very holy grail of effective
communication they will no name
structure so in terms of the audience
what humor does is actually create a
level of comfort and Trust it also makes
the presenter more likable and more
relatable this is exactly what we saw
advaithi at the exercise with Kent ago
secondly humor can be made a very
powerful agent in transmitting and
bearing the presenters intent that's
what we saw in the anecdotal story about
the Jester who managed to humor and
through that whimsical way to save his
own life and what is a Harding tent and
actually saving the presenters life and
certainly humor can be a very powerful
tool in amplifying and bearing the
message and making comments which would
otherwise be quite caustic and
Oren's blonde and this is what we all
are classmates they do the GSP show
regarding the efficacy of the
administration there's some very good
news for all of you you can start right
away to find ways to employ human
representations there are multiple
resources which are free and easily
accessible quite easily have a lot of
content on YouTube you can see great
speakers who have actually based their
very presentation skills and humor
itself you can also find a lot of
articles which are going to teach you
how to use humor effectively in verbal
communication a lot of books which take
a more scientific approach to the
subject and a lot of webinars and videos
on humor itself and even more specific
subjects around the blonde humor in
communication thanks very much for your
attention